pour en débattre à nos sommes nous avec
un patrick mennucci ancien député ps des
bouches de rhône bonsoir patrick
mennucci merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés didier maïsto président de sud
radio auteur de passager clandestin aux
éditions le diable vauvert of rage dans
lequel a un vivier vous raconter
notamment vaud marche tous les samedis
aux côtés des gilet jaune l'année
dernière bonsoir à vous merci d'être
avec nous alors là c'est quand on sait
qu'on vient de voir patrick mennucci
vous l'homme politique qu'est ce que
vous en pensez c'est le cauchemar de
tout responsable politique d'être ainsi
interpellé en pleine rue moi j'ai une
autre idée c'est que je crois que c'est
fait à dessein président république ne
peut pas imaginer se promener un 14
juillet dans le parc des tuileries
alors qu'il y a autour d'un certain
nombre de manifestations sans tomber sur
des personnes qui vont lui parler après
le niveau sonore la façon dont il
s'exprime
personne ne pouvait rien savoir mais il
est à peu près certaine je vous en parle
d'expérience de jeu qui a fait beaucoup
de politiques et qui s'est beaucoup
promené sur le vieux-port qu'un jeu
parti de chez moi pour aller à la mairie
j'étais absolument certain de tomber sur
les citoyens qu'ils allaient me parler
et donc je vois pas comment le président
de la république peut ignorer ce genre
de choses donc pour moi c'est fait
exprès c'est plutôt pas mauvais pour lui
parce que il est il démontre que bon il
est capable de parler les gens de toutes
façons soit en face du président la
république et à la fin prennent une
attitude plutôt respectueuse vert plutôt
correct en tout cas je pense que c'est
un bon petit coup politique auquel on
est habitué avec emmanuel macron analyse
que patrick mennucci une opération
séduction qui finalement se finit pas si
mal pour un emmanuel macron qui on
l'imaginé
j'appartiens à la à la reconquête de son
électorat perdu les quatorze eu et c'est
vrai il vaut mieux jouer au loto on a
toutes les chances de gagner quelle
belle martingale quel sens de l'à-propos
quelle séance parfaite
j'ai plaidé faire une interview avec des
journalistes quand même pas très
combatif bon goût surtout il à parler
pour ne rien dire
j'ai pas compris moi cette interview du
14 juillet à parra peut faucher l'herbe
sous le pied de son premier ministre
pour lui dire c'est moi le patron je
parle avant toi et de dire deux trois
trucs en scoop quoi bon j'avais j'ai pas
compris cette intervention donc il sait
puis s'il sort il se balade ses gardes
du corps autour il fait beau il a un
petit blouson en cuir
la picarde qui va bien il interpellé
tient par départ des gilet jaune juste
au moment où on l'a dit faut écouter les
territoires il faut écouter les braves
gens dans la rue etc et ja il tombe sur
un groupe de gilet jaune
ils disent aujourd'hui voilà il faut
être respectueux il était un peu
colérique au début puis à la fin il
n'arrive même pas le goût dire ils ont
été séduits convaincu complètement sous
le filtre d'amour de monsieur macro ça
fait quand même je sais pas si on est
dans le nouveau bond monsieur bellucci
connais par coeur
ça fait partie de la vie politique
traditionnelle en sommet en scène est
effectivement de la manipulation alors
que les premiers jardins des tuileries
il va être interpellé mais vous dites en
bas alors laissons ces nuits on
al'impression vous pensez à un coup
monté quand même pas je n'irai pas
jusque là mais je ne peux pas en tant
que journaliste connaisseurs un petit
peu de des séquences politiques et des
images de campagne
g si vous les jeunes espèce de petit
radar je pense que tous les observateurs
qui connaissent bien les politiques en
ce petit radar qui se met en marche et
qui leur dit où la tension c'est trop
pleins faits là il s'est passé un truc
ça arrive pile au bon moment
dans le discours de politique générale
du premier ministre au moment où il
change de l'équipe en nous disant que
celle qui équipe qui venait d'exercer
avait toutes les qualités que c'est pour
ça qu'ils en changent et il nous parle
des changements d'une nouvelle direction
un nouveau virage sans que l'on sache
exactement quelle est cette direction ce
virage puisque c'était bien avant
alors voyez on est dedans on est dans le
en même temps et je suis là paraît que
monsieur bellucci c'est un petit un
petit coup politique vous allez on en
parle on en parle ce soir et la seconde
la seconde second moteur le second étage
de la fusée ça va être regardé quand
même monsieur castex issus des
territoires
le président pense fred et gilet jaune
monsieur castex avec tous sont sa
science et son don des rapports sociaux
etc
quand même y reçoit le pays essaie on
entre dans cette séquence là que les
médias accompagné peut-être que les
gilets jaunes qui étaient là ont ils
étaient les victimes consentantes ou pas
ce sont elles un peu fait piéger l'ontt
imaginée avec le président que sais je
ne peux pas lire ici c'est une manière
de dire voilà je ne veux laisser
personne sur le bas côté on se souvient
de cette séquence pendant la campagne
présidentielle où emmanuel macron avait
était pas mauvais il faut bien le dire
cette séquence marine le pen emmanuel
macron à quelques intervalles qui vont
je crois que c'était whirlpool l'usiné
fils paul et qui parle voilà ces
ouvriers effectivement en colère qui
d'abord et qui finit par lesquels mais
il sait qu'il n'est pas mauvais dans cet
exercice est effectivement c'est une
manière pour lui d'aller à la reconquête
de cet électorat qui ne s'est perdu en
tout cas pour l'instant
je crois que c'est exactement ce que
vous décrivez je suis d'accord avec
monsieur maisto choix connaître d'accord
tous les deux on connaît
côté l'autre delà de la réalité
médiatique de la politique du mans j'ai
dirigé une campagne présidentielle donc
je vois bien la force des images
je ne peux pas imaginer je crois que
tous les observateurs que le pôle isa la
république est là par hasard donc après
on ne lui a pas mis les gilet jaune sur
ce chemin mais on ne peut pas ne pas
savoir quand on marche dans le parc des
tuileries ce du jour de 14 juillet
comment rencontrer des gens donc est-ce
qu'ils avaient fusé avec tout à
sécuriser en amont quand on connaît
comment ça fonctionne on s'aventure pas
comme ça c'est sécuriser d'abord il ya
une première équipe qui va voir ils sont
reliés porté par talkie walkie par pas
bon et c'est sais c'est pas la situation
s'est un peu musclé volaille en rien un
qui le traitent voilà vous êtes non non
ployer alors je vous propose d'écouter
justement la réaction de jean-luc
mélenchon à cette phrase de ce gilet
jaune qui dit mais vous vous êtes
emmanuel macron monde employés écouter
les gens ont raison de dire que macro et
leurs employés moi aussi je suis
l'employé du peuple français c'est avoir
une conscience républicaine de dire cela
patrick mais une fille je voulais votre
réaction là dessus est ce qu'au final ça
ne bénéficient pas emmanuel macron voilà
ce gilet jaune de manière un peu musclée
du niveau là vous êtes mon employé on ne
peut ne pas être d'accord bien
évidemment avec le chef de l'état il
n'empêche qu'il a été élu
démocratiquement est ce que c'est une
manière de parler qui est approprié
aujourd'hui où finalement vous trouvez
que voilà comme le dit jean luc
mélenchon on exprime pour reprendre les
expressions de certaines est une forme
de colère saine dans les camps tome dit
à quelqu'un vous êtes mon employé c'est
généralement pas positif
en tout cas moi cette expression que je
j'abhorre que je n'emploierai jamais il
jean louis raiche on a tort de justifier
ce genre d'expression parce que ce n'est
pas l'emploi y est de la personne dont
il parle c'est juste le président de la
république qui a été élu lors ci fait
référence à ce salaire oui effectivement
il est en partie constituée de nos
impôts enfin je dirais c'est pas très
intéressant ce qui me paraît intéressant
mois plus tôt c'est c'est la séquence
c'est à dire une une interview qui fut
très honnêtement de de faible niveau
moi j'ai pas tout compris en l'écoutant
je vous que même un peu de mal à
comprendre ce qui se disait
des journalistes qui étaient plutôt
accommodants disons ensuite on a cet
épisode aux tuileries et puis cette
après midi on a le jean castex
je crois que c'est ça qui aujourd'hui
est important qu'est ce qui dit jean
castex
cet après midi il dit on avait un
désaccord avec la droite dans ce pays
c'est la question de la sécurité par
contre sur l'économie grosso modo on est
d'accord et donc ils essayent d'en
rajouter sur la question de la sécurité
est comme ça ils vont arriver à
phagocyter le candidat qui les inquiète
qui pourrait les inquiéter le plus parce
qu'ensuite il y aura le candidat
peut-être de la gauche et des
écologistes qui posera un problème c'est
le candidat de la droite donc nous
sommes dans une stratégie qui va durer
quelques mois qui consiste à ne pas
permettre à xavier bertrand
hu à un autre candidat issu des
républicains d'émerger donc on envoie un
premier ministre comme jean castex qui
vient du parti républicain qui très
honnêtement un discours cet après midi
qui est un discours de droite assez
simple et qui prend en compte la
situation la nécessité de la de la
relance économique il ya deux choses
dans le discours de jean castex d'après
midi il ya la relance ayant la sécurité
et en plus je crois qu'il y a réellement
et sage pour moi c'est plutôt positif
il y a réellement
la volonté de d'éclairer la question de
la laïcité
et c'est vrai qu'il ya un alignement des
ministres qui est plus clair qu'avec le
gouvernement précédent sion probable en
guerre si on prend darmanin et si on
plante castex on est sur des jeunes qui
sont d'accord sur la laïcité c'est pour
ça à mon avis qu'on annonce la loi
contre le séparatisme et enfin peut-être
enfin peut-être là le discours du
président la république qu'on nous
annonce depuis trois ans et demi sur la
laïcité
donc je pense que c'est ça qui se passe
cet après midi c'est la volonté de faire
en sorte que ne puisse pas émerger un
candidat de la droite et après le
président république se dit et je verrai
pour la gauche
un peu plus tard on va d'ailleurs je
vous propose d'écouter un extrait voilà
par infographie de ce discours de jean
castex qui en quelque sorte répond au
gilet jaune puisque c'était notre
postulat de départ pour ce débat écoutez
je sais pour la côtoyer tous les jours
qu'il existe une france qui ne dit rien
mais qui n'en pensent pas moins
une france du bon sens et de la raison
une france que nous devons aujourd'hui
écoutés et mieux considérés alors là
didier maïsto effectivement comme le
souligne patrick mennucci voilà on est
vraiment cette france qu'on n'écoute pas
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque du marketing du marketing
je suis je suis ce qui est tout à fait à
l'analyse que vient de faire patrick
mennucci je rajouterais une pincée de
verre cia nous allons nous annonce que
pour relancer le pays
on va faire du vélo et de la rénovation
thermique est très bien pourquoi pas
après tout tous à vélo vous allez voir
dans les campagnes dans la ruralité
comment les gens vont vous y revenez
quand vous allez au real il ya pas ce
qu'il y'a qu'à paris à lyon à marseille
et à bordeaux qu'on fait du vélo c'est
tout bon
je ferme la parenthèse mais
effectivement on est on est dans du
marketing on est
on est dans du marketing et on voit
qu'il a bien bloqué d'ailleurs il avait
déjà fait avec edouard philippe heullant
là il en rajoute une petite louche avec
monsieur castex qui est compatible qui
est malléable mais qui a l'apparence
comme ça d'être un peu rugueuse avec un
accent qui fait authentique et toutes
les deux phrases il pourrait y prononce
le mot territoire on sait là aussi c'est
complètement obscur parce qu'on nous dit
qu'on va aller vers une nouvelle étape
de décentralisation et nous parle
surtout des déconcentrations en
redonnant du pouvoir au département en
faisant exploser probablement la
fonction publique territoriale qui a
déjà explosé avec une catastrophe qui
nous amenait avec tous ces
fonctionnaires qui ne fonctionne pas
qu'ils sont des administratifs jeu quand
je vois les ars et toutes les
catastrophes française et tu sais ces
fromages qu'on empile les uns sur les
autres alors il faut savoir soit c'est
en une république française avec un
territoire bien compris et acceptés
seront donne le pouvoir aux régions ont
fait des lander soit on revient un peu à
une conception plus traditionnels issus
de la peau les os et on dit la française
département mais tout à la fois quand on
voit aujourd'hui la situation d'un autre
économie relancée comme ça deux des
défauts emploi disant l'initiative dans
les territoires où ils s'attirent et des
hommes dans les territoires mais sont
pas les fonctionnaires qui vont libérer
les énergies toutes ces formules creuses
que j'ai encore entendu mais ça fait
trente ans que je les entends justement
sur ces territoires
ce droit la différenciation d'ailleurs
des territoires qui sera consacré dans
une loi organique
ça vous parle je moi moi j'avais cru
comprendre
d'un certain nombre d'interventions du
président la république du premier
ministre il ya une semaine qu'on allait
s'orienter vers en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on a dit à la réunion des dés de
l'association des régions de france qui
présidait paronnaud muselier souvenez
vous il ya une quinzaine de jours renaud
muselier va voir le président de la
république il y à une colle une réunion
zoom avec l'ensemble des présidents de
région et on annonce à ce moment là que
le président république va repousser les
élections régionales pour faire une loi
de décentralisation nouvelle donner plus
de pouvoir aux régions ça a disparu
s'est passé dans un dans un trou je ne
sais absolument pas lequel aujourd'hui
on nous parle de la fonction publique
départementale
mais la fonction publique départementale
excusez moi ça n'existe pas il existe à
la fonction publique territoriale et la
fonction publique territoriale s'est
majoritairement les municipalités n'ont
pas les départements donc je n'arrive
pas bien comprendre même dans les mots
qui sont employées ce qu'on veut dire en
réalité je crois qu'on veut noyer le
poisson médias quoi ça me fait penser
c'est la question vous vous posez là
monsieur maïs terme en début et en fin
de votre intervention
moi ça me fait penser un peu aux
pompidolisme
monsieur le premier ministre et il l'a
démons et est-ce que derrière il y aura
au moins les constructions dont avait
été capable
le premier ministre georges combes îlots
moi je pense surtout qu'ils manquent des
choses de ce discours est ce qu'il ya un
référendum sur l'article 1 de la
constitution concernant l'environnement
ça nous a été annoncé mais là on est
dans un discours à l'assemblée nationale
on n'en parle plus est ce qu'il y à une
réforme du parquet on a vu que on avait
un premier on avait un ministre un garde
des sceaux qui s'est exprimé en disant
je viens parce que je vais faire une
réforme du parquet sous-entendu on va
aller vers l'indépendance accrues des
magistrats
le premier ministre n'en dit pas un mot
or c'est un élément essentiel de la
république de la façon dont on vit j'ai
vu il ya quelques jours que on dit on
nous parle de la proportionnelle c'est
une pression qui est faite par françois
bayrou et le modem éternellement sur le
président public
il n'y a pas un mot est ce qu'on aurait
pu s'attendre quand même parce que
peut-être que jean castex à force de
regarder les territoires ils regardent
plus l'europe mais il ya quand même des
déclarations hier et avant-hier d'angela
merkel y compris du président polonais
lui qui pourtant n'est pas un européen
convaincu du danemark de l'italie qui
parle de la taxe sur les transactions
financières qui permettrait de financer
500 milliards de de 2 500 milliards
d'euros et de permettre de rajouter ça
la relance
pas un mot du premier ministre devant
l'assemblée nationale or c'est quand
même une déclaration de la chancelière
qui kane tout à fait importante et
nouvelles donc voilà je suis un peu je
suis un peu stupéfait de la façon dont
ça se passe parce qu'il ya un seul but
en réalité c'est celui de
de marabouté la droite parce que la
gauche là il n'y a rien pour la gauche
de ce discours ou pas grand-chose maisto
l'a dit un peu des vélos moment là mais
c'est surtout pour la droite que c'est
fait et pour empêcher l'émergence d'un
candidat type dit bertrand à l'élection
présidentielle merci en tout cas à tous
les deux patrick mennucci didier maïsto
d'avoir été avec nous pour décrypter
l'actualité la séquence emmanuel macron
et et gilet jaune est évidemment
l'actualité de jours avec ce discours de
politique générale du premier ministre
qui a été adoptée je vous le rappelle
avec 345 voix dans l'hémicycle ce soir
merci à tous les deux